[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
george was it was hanging [ __ ] up you do
that
you do that when when the
papa is
not here yeah
you don't do that when he's here ready
to go yeah george you you you you know
what george said to me last night who
showed up last night george i did right
with my dog and i said george where uh
call your wife that what
what did you say don't call your wife
i'll call her whatever the [ __ ] i want i
bought her
i said to george i said hey man what are
we going to do tonight and i dropped off
some stuff and he said i'm going to put
up some shelves
yeah didn't do it one shelf one shelf do
it did it right now if everyone can see
at home i don't know if you can screws
sticking out holes in the wall yeah
that's so good and then not so good the
cacti yeah one cacti
you know what dude one a one
don't do that
don't
do you get that from me do you think
that you're closer to andrew because
andrew is more in touch of black culture
or
understands the people better i don't
even feel like it's about closeness i
just feel like he's just exactly what
the [ __ ] he said yeah you have no clue
[Applause]
so for the last 20 years right that
we've been [ __ ] with each other right
yeah you've always felt that about me
that you was yeah there's a disconnect
between me
and your culture
not the i mean i don't know i don't know
nothing about the coat bobby
statement the statement is wrong
reframe it for me
but the way you're saying it the [ __ ]
said see it in your way in an urban way
why don't
see that's what i'm talking about that's
it
when you go i don't know what's wrong
with me yes you do know what's wrong
with you what you're weak
redheaded people have weak everything
right so whatever it is
so
you you're saying you're saying koreans
are the strongest people in the world uh
here we go here we go
have you were you oppressed by the
japanese for 50 years
were you
you my people were okay all right why
because yeah
olympic weight lifters korean
uh
let's see let's see the lineup yeah yeah
yeah uh jang miran great great
weightlifter jiang miranda you can take
two rice [ __ ] pots and with one hand
and pull it with his right hand
weight lifter from south korea lift uh
list ready yeah
jang miran
great
she is currently based in goyang you're
top waiting
is great you're talking about
is the is the epicenter of korean
weightlifting all right
we have a great gym called uh
gym
and it's the best
it says right here the highest the most
she's ever lifted is 200 if you want to
google that 200 if you want a google
friend let's go she lifted two hundred
sonatas
all right
all right uh ji hoon min
ji hoon min south korea weight lifter he
completed featherweight division
in beijing olympic games in 2008 last
time he failed to successfully lift the
clean and jerk he was disqualified these
are some of your best by the way i'm
naming that's great that's great okay
don't try to tell me that my people are
weak and yours are strong but we could
can play that game though you know
you're the one that came after me you
came after me irish ping pong players
let's go oh my god so
when they're going up the stairs i go
here's my chance so i um pretend i was
dead
i go here's my chat so i laid on the
ground right
why would you do that dead you just laid
down i just laid down like i was dead
did you put any blood out or anything no
no but i just i made my body like as if
i was like fell in a weird way right
down the stairs no just up in the living
room well they wouldn't buy that would
you would you had a heart attack maybe i
get it maybe you could so i'm laying
there and i can see her she can see me
from the kitchen who can
her oh right she's putting stuff away or
whatever right
she looks at me
she still does her thing then she
eventually goes cheeto bobby
like no
no are you okay nothing is everything go
is everything all right nothing nothing
absolutely nothing wow so let me ask you
something you didn't believe it at all i
didn't what did you think he was doing
sleeping i saw his eyes open and closed
oh you're not good at playing dead bro
you're not good at playing dead andrew
do it right now do die right now
what you saw that's didn't look good all
right okay
no that's not what your face is
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's more
like it like you're sucking a little
penis or something no
yeah yeah trembling lip you're dead i'll
go i'll go dead for you ready this is me
dead
no no no no that's motionless you're
falling asleep in a movie theater this
is me falling this is me that is me
no you're drunk you're drunk i'm drunk
yeah yeah yeah this this is uh this is
me dad
yep you're dead
when you go in for an audition if they
say we need an accent what do you do i
had to do boston today do boston for me
can you do i'll do a lie and you'd stay
in line i'll try okay all right go ahead
i'll say exactly from the show ready
okay
he goes uh
it's uh
that's uh yeah he said
yeah great
hold on i have to look i have to look
away from it now yeah no no i have to
close my eyes while i do if i look at
you while i do it's going to be hard
just don't do the [ __ ] audition just
do a line that you would say if you're
from boston oh bro yeah [ __ ] over
there where uh
yeah that's where uh that's that's where
we live that's why brady's the best he's
the best quarterback
quarterback i can't do it there's no way
i could do it brady
buddy ready
okay
now you sound like a little italian yeah
that's how you should have read this
yeah here's the thing dude did you
really audition for a marvel movie today
i did did you feel good about it
the first take now but i thought that
you're not gonna what are you gonna be
in the movie not a superhero good god no
you'll be like that's so [ __ ] rude
that you said that do you think you have
a superhero body
it doesn't matter yeah it does
name a superhero that looks like you um
toad from x-men
you know what
we should go on a date you and i yeah
why don't we go on a date we'll film it
why don't we go on a real date
i'm dead serious it's so gross dude
would you go on a date with me for you
please
but take it serious all right but i'm
serious like take it for real like dress
up look nice all right let's do your
makeup do your hair
no i want to we're at a restaurant i
want to go to a real date no we will but
let's disc
so let's how does it work i pick you up
well then rudy i pick you up
no i'm the i am the guy
you pick me up i pick you up will you
pick me up on time
you won't be ready so i'll be late
you know me well i know very good yeah
that gets me around a little bit because
we have a connection there so you know
rudy you're our server okay all right no
wait for you pick me up first you're at
the restaurant yet all right sorry
yeah
what's up man
you know walk out the door and say hi
and walk down the stairs
there he is close the door yeah right
hi hi bob
get in
andy
get in oh are you gonna open the
oh my god i'm sorry
[Laughter]
i opened the door and then
thank you
yeah yeah
and then we would have to mum we would
have to talk about something that's a
little uncomfortable no i would probably
look nice tonight i go do you no
you would this all right you wouldn't
you wouldn't open with that you look so
intimate you look nice tonight
thank you
you know it's funny i um i would say
something nervous because right so i'll
go yeah because um you know i i just
joined amazon you know i figured out how
to get amazon stuff and i got these new
men's soap oh yeah yeah yeah so i got a
collection in a box like and one of them
is like patchouli but one of the this
charcoal one yeah and so like and you
know i i saved the charcoal one you know
for a special occasion yeah you smell
good
thank you for noticing let's go you
ready to go get some food
where are we gonna go it's a surprise
okay
and then we would have another awkward
thing where i'd go we'd speak at the
same time like a bad movie you know yeah
so
oh oh okay
go ahead go ahead oh you you oh
are your tags up to date no i think
everything is okay oh uh hi officer how
can i help you
why were you speeding up oh gosh i
didn't i didn't think i was speeding
yeah we're going over 60.
oh was i what's the speed limit here
55.
and you just
let me
interrupt please so you thought that
five miles per hour was a little too
much for you to handle
and you pulled us over yes well wow okay
well let me do this i'm on a date you're
gonna give us a ticket though no not yet
i'm on a date
i'm on a date as you can see
yeah yeah yeah where are you going well
it's a surprise it's a surprise it's
yeah i've known him for years and then
we just we just started we realized we
just wanted to try it out yeah yeah yeah
why did you have to bring your little
video game everywhere you go because you
can't leave home with that you can't
leave home without that it's not a
little video it's called a switch
okay yeah and you're 50.
48. how many 50 year olds do you know
have a nintendo switch i don't know any
of them you don't know any no you've got
to be the only one yeah i see the
statistics on that
how many 50 year olds in the united
states have a nintendo switch
there's no way there's a statistic on
that
it'll just say populate it'll go to my
[ __ ] uh six
you know who has you know what says your
name is first bobby lee and then i just
said who's number two on there
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
why would that ever matter why would you
why would it matter what our names are i
just like um
taking people taking gay people's names
what's your badge number what is your
badge number one yeah we can really
report it
we're gonna report you like
write that down
we'll be on your our way thank you so
much
i'm andrew
no well why do you need our names what
are your names
i like to keep it on my
house you pull over gay people you get
their names you just kind of like you
know write it on the walls of your house
wow okay how can we get it now well
we'll be on our way you know we've been
watching 90 day fiance love it hold on
finish your story all right let me
finish the story so so you're in the
basement kalyal texts you and says what
you [ __ ] idiot
he doesn't have hiv you [ __ ] idiot he
does andrew call me and he said yeah
they have yeah and um she goes no he's
just joking so then i called you and
then you laugh my point is is this how
do why would you think
and i mean my point is is this is is
that when you prank somebody and you
they say stuff like that at the end of
the phone call you go i was just kidding
you don't it you don't let it [ __ ]
live how would you not know that i was
kid i wasn't it was so obvious i was
joking around people could have right
people no
not anymore yeah we know a guy that has
it i know but he got in like 86. he has
it i know but no one gets it you know i
know he hasn't i've never gave him a hug
right all the things that you want to
ask me now please because we're really
late for a reservation um do you have
any um
hairstyle that you would have stuff well
i like the roman cut
i like the roman cut and i also like uh
when they shave the sides what do they
call it when they shave the sides oh for
me oh i said i'm sorry um your hair
looks great oh my god maybe making some
bangs do it like a bob bank you could
easily get out get away should i get a
tattoo
um we don't know
you at all what would your tattoo be
oh yeah um i lost my dog so i wanted oh
so you lost his dog
so you want to tattoo your dog
officer dominguez
i'm going to throw this out there this
is crazy but do you want to just come
with us to dinner
sure
should just park your car that's all you
have to do no i don't want to interrupt
your first date no it's funny
you already have three then you're gonna
um pull us over again so right okay do
you promise not to pull us over again i
promise you okay okay so you're not
coming with us
and so you've asked every question that
you want you're not gonna pull over
server or again yes okay thank you have
a good night have a good night offers
are doing against your time
all right all right let's go please
crazy
finally we're here at the restaurant
oh my god so what do you think about
have you ever seen this place oh luigi's
luigi's yeah yeah yeah delicious yeah
and is it based on the mario brothers
well the iron is it's luigi's but it's
actually argentinian food wow yeah have
you ever had it not really no it's
breaded breaded chicken it's steaks a
lot of steaks and chim-chori sauce and
stuff like that you're gonna love it
okay good you're gonna love it uh oh
there's the host down there there's the
host uh let's hello sir hello hello
welcome to luigi's
thank you thank you thank you
i guess there's a reservation under the
name of santino it's actually what it's
santeenly because i thought we would
that's cute that's really cute yeah
is there a santini here for 8 30. uh
um no i'm sorry what the [ __ ] wait i i
called it did you call it i made it on
open table i put it on open table and i
also called and made sure that you guys
still had the table on the terrace that
i requested
um i don't see it here maybe you guys
can take it to go
hold on one second
first of all i'm sorry um it's under
centennial but this is andrew santino
and my name is bobby lee maybe you know
who we are ian so we have a podcast
called bad friends it's pretty popular
oh i thought that was with uh tom segura
and bear crisis um okay embarrassing
what's your name sir yeah beat
man do you not sound like a p
but pablo oh peter
you're the rapper petey pablo yeah yes
well listen here pete pablo
um
i have a weird feeling and you can say
i'm wrong but are you not giving us our
table because
we're two guys on a date
yeah it looks a little bad for our
clientele
that's disgusting that's disgusting you
know we don't want to eat at a place
like luigi's
you know because this is
you know when if you did an asian woman
i wouldn't be creeped out it's when guys
like look like mitch mcconnell yeah he's
walking down the street with a 19 year
old i hate that because that's fetish
it's not just fetish like because i was
in thailand and i would see like 90 year
old x packs
ex pats
pets
not x packs oh whatever
and um i'd see 96
packs xbox
and they would walk down the street with
like a 19 year old 18 year old young
girl yeah i don't like that it's so
[ __ ] gross it's so gross like my
brother's neighbor i can't say his name
why i can't is he a creep no but could
they do business together and i love the
guy oh but he can't get any women right
now
is he ugly no he's he's like george but
with chunks
oh he's like a fat george yeah yeah yeah
fat george is not so good yeah yeah
skinny jordans ain't that good either
yes it is skinny george isn't bad well
he's getting [ __ ]
but it's like this guy could get it if
he tried but he doesn't try so i guess
dream is to go to thailand eventually
and get a wife
really yeah does he do the thing where
he orders them
you can set it up online that when you
get there they're already waiting for
you and [ __ ] could you do that i saw a
tv show all about it yeah what i need to
do is get me the top thousand
put them in a room
if i was you know the top thousand
thai girls yeah okay that you have
available and you just get to pick yeah
and i could just walk around sex slavery
what's your name and i go
right and i go hey can i just call you
no
i go [ __ ] you and i walk by you know
what i mean that's right
it's already an issue
yeah yeah if i want to do one though
oh you only want to yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then if you know
they're hot but then they open their
mouth and it's like chernobyl in her
mouth i can't do that yeah yeah yeah
it's like
pass on that right chernobyl in their
mouth you know how sometimes they open
you know you're they're hot and then
they open their mouth and it's like one
tooth one tooth here and the rest are
like
roots
don't like it
you see that all the time well i've been
to thailand in the brothels a lot
hello officer
dominguez i'm not talking to you i'm
talking to pete pablo oh
wow
i know pete pablo oh yeah oh okay oh you
guys are probably gonna have a
conversation yeah
he's my brother
oh no oh that makes sense
yeah wow
he's refusing a table because we're on a
date yes
pete
no i love gays
you have to let them in
okay let them in let us have a table
pete would that be okay yes pete okay
all right thank you thank you
thank you officer dominguez we really
appreciate it um
can i sit with you
honestly
we might as well we have to at this we
might as well at this point after this
yeah so okay come sit with us
let's put up a chair let me take out let
me fill your chair thank you no problem
and dominguez i'll do this for you as
well just because we're here uh there's
our server hi uh how hey hi hello
oh so you oh you do hope so one man
shop do you cook as well
i do
oh
okay are you argentinian i am
wow wow so do you have any specials
chimichurri steak
cherry steak that's all you've got
that's it can we get a menu chimichurri
steak that's all they serve that's all
they serve
well do you guys want to put in a drink
order or something like that do you want
something to drink to me guess i want
a lemonade a lemonade
because you only have chimichurri steak
here so
what are the options it doesn't seem
like you would have lemonade
we have wine wine and water and water
okay with lemon we can put lemon you can
put lemon in the water yup or the wine
would you like water
lemon water
will that suffice um i don't drink i
don't drink so i'll have just i guess a
water okay i don't really want wine i
i'll just have some water as well are
you sure there's nothing there's like
nothing else back there
we have uh energy drinks oh oh well i'll
have an energy drink
what brand we have red bulls perfect
perfect i'll have this you have a sugar
free red bull no only with sugar uh okay
i'll have a regular red bull fine we'll
take we'll take those yeah thank you so
much what a weird rust frog i mean
honestly just chimcharis wine yeah
chimichurri steak
red
red bull
and water and water that's it that's it
i like it i don't know how this is in
business
so dominguez uh oh yeah sir and we'll
just take three steaks obviously because
we [ __ ] can't choose anything because
can we can we um medium
okay do we have an option
can we do medium no yes medium that's
the only thing you do yeah i'd like
medium rare if that's possible no that's
not they only have medium you can just
undercook it a little bit they only have
media this chef doesn't like suggestions
so yeah yeah
okay so i guess we'll have three medium
cherry steaks
i'll have a red bull you want a red bull
three red bulls
water lemon water water's all around
yeah but no lemon for mine no lemon for
his please yeah no ice in mine please if
you could yeah
uh did you get all that
let me write it down why don't you do
you you can't memorize that can you
repeat it back to us so we make sure you
have the order memorize
[Laughter]
yes of course that's precisely what we
wanted
okay three three red bulls
yes please
and two waters
one with ice the other one would live on
yeah yeah yes please got it last night
i'm having a great day i'm downstairs
playing witcher 3 just going on some
adventures trying to find another sword
and then i i get a uh
text from this piece of [ __ ] yeah go
ahead play it here's what delia texted
bobby was
my special came out
[Music]
it's killing
[Laughter]
[Music]
you should do one you know
just get it together i'm [ __ ] doing
already yeah
but you don't
you know
and you won't
is it because you're a [ __ ]
that's it
that's the video let's criticize the way
it looks though
okay number one crystalia all right
i don't know
[Music]
what a weirdo okay
look at this yeah look at this though
yet another look at this face yet
another uh goofball tattoo from chris
paper another a paper airplane dumb he's
three for three on bad tats right his
lips are like remember that
amphibian amphibian character in hellboy
oh yeah yeah he has the his he does yeah
they're always wet yeah delia's lips are
always [ __ ] wet soaked soaked because
yeah you know why why because he does
this all the time yeah
is that what he does all the time i see
him lick his lips all the time oh that's
what it is he wants wet lips yeah he
wants it he wants to be wet lips let's
call him wet lips from now on so wetlip
sent you this text did you text him back
yeah i texted him i'll show you what i
texted him i go
because when he sends me videos like
this all the [ __ ] time
and i get so angry i don't know why well
he does he sends me this video i just
said i'm going to hurt you
what'd he say no i think he never
responded yeah
in fact he didn't hurt you then didn't
you yeah i mean one time he sent me a
video of
aren't my dogs cute
ugh so he has two dogs i think they have
three i thought whatever two or three
dogs running around being cute
but they're running on top of a pile of
money yeah it's hilarious
that's so funny stardew valley star
dubali
if you do another asian accent that was
an asian that was robotic stardew valley
oh that's true that was robotics yeah
that's what stephen stephen hawking new
valley
valley yeah okay that's it you have to
go up start do that yeah
uh rest in peace
western peace what star doing what were
you going to say about the
you think if you're paralyzed and you
die they just fold you because
they don't need to you don't need a long
time they could put you in a dwarf
casket actually oh yeah yeah yeah that's
really good yeah like if you know if
brad williams dies they'll use brad or
stephen hawkins he already has his shoe
box picked out
and he just had a baby he did have a
little bit yeah and the delivery was uh
20 seconds long because all she did is
queef and just fell onto the ground yeah
and it was like a little thing like
yeah
it's like a rice pod that's what it
sounds like
[Laughter]
we're about to re-enact one of my
favorite scenes from the irishman okay
well can i watch the movie first before
we nope that's the best part okay could
i beat joe petro
[Music]
okay you can either be you can either be
um
jimmy hoffa
oh i want to be jimmy alpha do you know
who jimmy hoff is yeah he was a union
guy okay so you want to be jimmy hoffa
and he disappeared that's right you want
you want to be jimmy hoffa yeah okay
that's jimmy hoffa's lines
and i'm going to be and i'm going to be
um tony pro and if people have seen the
movie know that who tony pro is okay i
want you to act this out very seriously
all right all right okay no no let me
let's [ __ ] read it let's do it the
right way okay ready this is i'm just
rehearsing this for the oscar season all
right ready yeah in interior private
club miami day 1972
frank and jimmy waited a table for tony
protocol where can i improvise [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] can i improvise yeah okay frank and
jimmy waited a table for tony pro to
show up jimmy checks his watch looks at
frank a
[ __ ]
it
yes cut
you're gonna have to get through the
first line if we're gonna be able to do
it i'm improvising you have to get
through the first line without a doubt
you're gonna have to get through
oh you still i can't that's improvising
[ __ ] a [ __ ]
you you did a record scratch [ __ ] it
four times but read that read the thing
again interior private club miami day
1972 forget about it okay jimmy
frank and jimmy waited a table for tony
pro to show up jimmy checks his watch
looks at frank [ __ ] it let's go
let's give him a few more minutes this
isn't right you don't do this you don't
make a man wait i know i know the only
time you do that is when
when you want to say something you know
when you want to say [ __ ] you
that's the only thing
frank nods they wait jimmy getting
madder by the second finally a white
cadillac pulls out front and pro wearing
shorts and a short sleeve shirt comes in
with his cousin-in-law tony jack
who unlike pro is wearing enough clothes
to conceal a piece and join jimmy and
frank at the table
can you believe this weather people are
freezing at that in new york and look at
us it's 80 outside it's perfect why
don't we live here year round is what i
want to know
[Music]
hey it's
it's summer what
hey summer you know people are freezing
the dead in new york in my mind it's
always eight degrees in new york
i'm making a point
this is how you dress for a meeting this
is how you dress and fly it
in a suit
for me
if it's florida
and you're late
what you've laid
there was traffic
it's never been late for a meeting in my
life wasn't there traffic there was i
never wait for anybody who late most for
more than 10 minutes uh i'd say 15 15 is
right no no no
10. i don't think so 10 is not enough
you gotta take traffic into account that
is taking traffic into account buddy
that's why it's 10. i still say 15.
10. fine we disagree on that
more than 10
you're saying something
are you saying something to me
i'm here that says what it says what can
i do for you
i want to ask you for endorsement or
something whoa whoa before you tell me
let's get the other thing straightened
out
i can't do anything about your pension
now if it's out there with fits there
you should talk about your fits about i
did
he says i'll take care of it no
questions asked you wouldn't do that but
he will i meant the other thing the
other thing you know i don't know you're
apologizing my apology for what what you
said when you were sitting there eating
your [ __ ] ice cream like some [ __ ]
king that was an ethnic slur you people
apologize for that
after you apologize for being late you
[ __ ] whoop [ __ ] i'll
apologize for being late after i kidnap
your granddaughter rip her guts out and
send him into you in a [ __ ] envelope
wow we did it how was it was that dead
on just like
was that just like the movie i just feel
like it was that's why i think we should
win in a [ __ ] we should win we should
win something for that
[Music]
it's a dark place
[Music]